today the state highlighting the work
being done to get vaccines out to the
public so far nevada has received 324
thousand doses
and they have administered 248 thousand
now the second dose clinic opened in
clark county at the las vegas convention
center earlier today
that's over near d.i and paradise and
tonight the work continues to get
more shots out joe mohler covering that
very busy day there joe
brian we can't stress enough that the
las vegas convention center is only for
second doses and people have been coming
throughout the day and those we caught
up with say this
process was pretty quick and easy
really quick very organized normally
around this time of year these buildings
are full of convention goers
now they operate as the next coveted
fighting site there wasn't a long line
they directed everyone to where they
needed to go i thought it was really
good
judy lilly works in the medical field
she says she was in and out in about 20
minutes
when the first mega site at cashman
center opened people were waiting hours
but they have since changed the
registration system
had my previous card from my lasting
vaccine
with me they took a look at that looked
at my driver's license
vaccines remain limited the health
district receives around 25 thousand
doses a week
the convention center location will
administer fourteen hundred doses a day
but can expand to three thousand
some are worried about getting an
appointment for their second vaccine on
time
we ask the public to constantly go back
and even if there says no appointments
are there
constantly check those for for new
appointments that open up
as we get some of this vaccine that
comes back we open up more appointments
there are also updates to the vaccine
rollout plan
in order to get more doses out emergency
medical personnel do not need to hold a
vaccine endorsement
in order to get the shots and clinics
are not subject to capacity limitations
we learned federal vaccinators were sent
to nevada to help
the team of 40 ndms personnel will split
into smaller task forces
to support several vaccination sites
across the state
30 of those vaccinators are here lily
hopes the state can get more vaccines
soon we can almost get back to normal i
hope
this location is by appointment only and
you have to have already had your first
appointment done that first dose at a
southern nevada health district site
and once you do have that done you'll be
sent an email to set up this appointment
here reporting live at the convention
center this evening joe mohler 8 news
now
and just to repeat again that's for the
second dose there thanks joe